qui est derrière ces cyber attaques
quand on dit rançon jce yale est ce que
c'est devenu une nouvelle pratique très
répandue
on a invité patrick mathieu expert en
sécurité informatique pour nous
expliquer tout ça bonsoir monsieur
mathieu alors est ce que ça vous étonne
l'emploi parce qu'on dit que l'attak
actuellement contre les centres
hospitaliers aux états unis au canada à
montréal même est une attaque majeure
est-ce que d'abord vous le croyez et
est-ce que c'est commun est ce que c'est
une première que ce soit si largement
répandue que ça le type d'attaqué très
commun ils rien de spécial ce niveau là
c'est devant l'ampleur qui fait que
c'est différent mais on se n'attendait
quand même un peu parce qu'on en a parlé
au début de la pandémie que les hôpitaux
tout qu'est-ce qui est services de santé
allait être une des cibles de choix pour
les criminels parce que justement durant
la pandémie ce sont des services
extrêmement critique et reporter alors
qu'est ce que font on parle du
changement drake qui est derrière ça
mais d'abord comment ça fonctionne
qu'est ce qu'ils font et pourquoi ils
sont ils aussi efficace à le faire en
fait le concept de l'attak qu'on parle
de rechange du ciel run somewhere c'est
un virus informatique qui vont être
introduits généralement puis presque
dans 90 % des cas dans vie aux courriels
donc un employé dans une entreprise dans
un hôpital dans ce cas ci va recevoir un
courriel qui al'air légitime la personne
va cliquer sur une pièce jointe ou out
et le virus va s'installer à partir de
là ça ouvre une porte vers les criminels
seraient internet et e commence à se
diffuser l'intérieur du réseau de
l'entreprise du réseau informatique
d'après certains moments qui ont réussi
à voir à leur possession des dizaines
des centaines voire des milliers de
serveurs
ils vont télécharger toutes les données
et ensuite les 1 crypté
donc ils vont mettre un mot de passe
dessus pour plus qu on ya accès et les
systèmes devient hors service ça ne
fonctionne plus ils vont demander une
rançon généralement pour
donnez le monde passe à ces services là
pour décrypter des chiffres et la donner
pour que les services redevienne actifs
le problème c'est que ils ont
généralement télécharger l'information
donc il faut aussi une deuxième demande
de rançon pour dire ben rhdp moi encore
je ne diffuserait pas vos informations
confidentielles sensible et interop l'on
parle de données médicales c'est
extrêmement sensible oui donc ces deux
ratios une après l'autre
est ce qu'on sait s'ils dépassent que
dans le cas de l'hôpital jeux de
montréal qui était la cible le sus du
centre ouest de montréal qui était la
cible de l'attaqué
on a réussi à je pense on a mis des pare
feu informatiques montrent qu'on a
réussi à protéger les acquis parce qu'on
a tous fermés ont rouvert
bref on a réussi à s'en échapper mais ce
que selon vos informations et à des
hôpitaux ici ou ailleurs qui ont dû
payer
oui ce qui suit si l'os c'est que la
majorité du temps les entreprises les
organisations ministères et autres que
ce soit les hôpitaux diront pas tout de
suite ils ont payé faut faire des
demandes d'informations et autres pilot
présentement bulls est très actif puis
ça débute donc ne pas encore
l'information
est-ce que c'est déjà arrivé oui
plusieurs autres entreprises et
ministères que au lycée qui a eu des
paiements qui ont été faits mais le
problème avec ça c'est qu'on traite avec
des terroristes c'est pas parce qu'on
paye une demande de rançon
quand la confiance règne la personne
peut le lendemain dehors est vous avez
accès facilement un million de dollars
j'en voudrais deux autres donc c'est un
jeu très dangereux
tout à fait et bien joué j'avais fait
une entrevue il ya une année ou deux sur
ce phénomène là mais personnel les gens
qui se faisaient à voir avec leur
cellulaire toutes les photos et textes
et puis l'on demandait aux gens un
certain montant pour débloquer le
système a cédé pour des personnels pour
des gens ça doit continuer à se fermer
des institutions c'est pas des blagues
on a demandé 2,8 millions à la stm
pour débloquer le système la cm avait
été l'objet d'une attaque comme celle là
donc c'est très sérieux
c'est très sérieux puis voulu mentionner
salle à commencer par des personnes mais
le sabot jurèrent les grandes
entreprises les grandes organisations
parce que c'est là que l'argent et c'est
beaucoup plus facile de dire je fais une
attaque et je demande deux millions que
je pirate 200 personnes pour avoir même
pas une centaine de milliers de dollars
le problème aussi avec la st1 où les les
hôpitaux le pourquoi que ça arrive puis
qui se font avoir c'est carrément un
manque de budget priorité de la sécurité
de l'information dans leur système
mais en fait c'est peut-être que les
équipes sur place ne sont pas capables
de protéger ou quoi que ce soit mais
tant qu'on n'aura pas une priorité de
2-0 veut sécuriser nous donner au québec
et au canada qu'on doit que le
gouvernement dise ou que les hôpitaux et
chuter rome est le vrai budget pour
sécuriser les choses il n'y a rien qui
va changer et si on parlait c'était me
disent que leur budget sécurité et un
million par année on parle de service
qui considérait critique pour la ville
de montréal
un budget de 1 million avec une dizaine
d'employés à peine pour couvrir une
région comme montréal ça équivaut à
quelques pilotes c'est de vous messieurs
parce que vous et d'autres l'appui je
sais pas exactement ce que vous faites
mais est ce que vous vous dites ça parce
que ça ferait travailler beaucoup
beaucoup d'experts en informatique
auprès des grandes fermes là où vous
dites ça parce que vraiment vous êtes
convaincus que nos grandes entreprises
sont mal protégés sont mal protégés puis
j'ai fait plusieurs entrevues juste
aujourd'hui j'ai été contacté par des
personnes dans des des écoles dans des
ministères pim design merci pour ces
entrevues là parce que tu le dis le
problème c'est le budget j'ai quelqu'un
qui me contacter pour une commission
scolaire la personne est tout seul à
gérer plusieurs écoles qui ont eu
d'échos de rennes sont moins une
personne il fallait qu'on passe d'une
équivalence d'une commission scolaire
s'est on devrait avoir une équivalence
de 57 200 personnes ont sécurité par une
bombe qui fait ça ou la traque mathieu
qui
fait ça c'est pas une personne dans son
sous-sol lecaplain d'écrans lcd
organisation quoi oui je sais c'est sûr
que ça pourrait arriver qu'une attaque
parmi tant d'autres ce soit quelqu'un
dans son sous sol mais qu'on parle d'eux
sans envergure locke la majorité des
attaques de rançon c'est des groupes
criminels organisés qui fonce au temps
plein c'est leur emploi c'est comme ça
qui font de l'argent ou sinon céder et a
donc là un peu comme il s'est discuté
aux états unis on parle de être la
russie la chine d'autres pays qui ferait
les attaques mais le problème c'est que
attribuer une attaque à quelqu'un c'est
extrêmement difficile
on a une image on va se quitter là
dessus c'est un site qui montera en
temps réel enregistre un peu plus tôt le
nombre de cyber attaques
c'est réaliste il y en a autant que ça
en fait ça c'est une vision d'une
entreprise qui montrent des attaques se
produisent sur leurs saveurs seulement
c'est pas réaliste dans le sens que ça
couvre pas tout mais ça donne une bonne
idée à monsieur madame tout le monde qui
nous écoutent
comme quoi que ces bombes acosta et on
est toujours sur un tacle il ya de
l'avenir dans ce métier-là
d'informaticienne de spécialistes en
sécurité patrick mathieu expert en
sécurité informatique merci nous avons
parlé merci et bonne soirée